hey this is presto Walker little-known
fact
Abraham Lincoln was a very good math
student while studying law
Lincoln frequently saw the word
demonstrate he wondered how a
demonstration was different from any
other proof he consulted Webster's
dictionary and he read that a
demonstration was a certain kind of
proof it meant to prove something beyond
any doubt but what did that mean still
confused Lincoln read more dictionaries
and more books but they still didn't
have the answer for him he decided he
had to learn what demonstrate meant in
order to become a good lawyer so he
paused his situation and went to his
father's home to study Euclid's elements
an ancient Greek text book about
geometry
Lincoln studied until he could
demonstrate any of the geometry
propositions at site satisfied he knew
what the word demonstrate meant he then
resumed his law studies this story comes
from Henry Ketchum's book the life of
Abraham Lincoln Wow he was a very
determined student and he was a very
good math student because of this so in
honor of Lincoln I want to share a
problem that he had while he was in
school if four men in five days eats
seven pounds of bread how much will be
sufficient for 16 men in 15 days this
comes from a manuscript that's held at
Harvard University and it's dated to
about when Lincoln was 16 years old the
problem also demonstrates how
mathematical attitudes are very
different today
imagine all the nitpicking comments such
a problem would receive if I posted it
as one of my puzzles or if it was in a
math textbook today but you know and I
know exactly what the problem is
about it's a test of proportions so with
that in mind can you solve a problem
that was part of Abraham Lincoln's math
homework give this problem a try and
when you're ready keep watching the
video for the solution so let's look at
Lincoln's calculations
well alright there are a lot of numbers
and there really is no explanation to go
with any of the steps but we do see at
the very end the answer of 84 pounds so
he did figure out the correct answer now
it's sort of a puzzle to figure out
exactly what he did
so I took the time to try and deduce
what his steps were so let me rewrite
his notes in modern notation the first
step that I would see in his notes is we
have 4 5 and 20 so I would guess he took
the form n times the five days to equal
a total of 20 man days we then have 16
times 15 so this would be 16 men times
15 days which ends up equaling 240 man
days and you could see he actually uses
the algorithm for multiplication that is
still taught in schools today now what
does he do from here well he takes the
240 man days he multiplies it by 7 and
divides it by 20 this will end up giving
the total amount of bread that's needed
for 240 man days given that you need 7
pounds of bread per 20 man days so he
first does 240 times 7 which gets 1680
he then takes 16 80/20 and that gets to
the answer of 84 pounds so there were a
few calculations involved
but he did get to the correct answer of
84 pounds and this is a valid method to
approach the problem however you can see
there is much potential for making a
mistake if he did 240 times 7
incorrectly he would not get the correct
answer so when I solved the problem
I used ratios to simplify the
calculation to reduce the chance of
making an error I first compared the
number of men that we need to solve for
versus the number of men we know so 16
men divided by four men is four times as
many men similarly 15 days divided by
five days is three times as many days so
in order to compute the ratio of the
Bann days we take 16 by 15 divided by
the quantity 4 times 5 and this
simplifies by these two ratios to be 4
times 3 therefore we need 12 times as
much bread so we then take 12 times as
much bread times 7 pounds of bread to
get to the answer of 84 pounds so for me
this is a little simpler but it doesn't
matter abraham lincoln was able to solve
the problem using his method so it's
demonstrates that he was a very good
math student and he was able to go
through all these calculations by hand
and get to the correct answer did you
figure it out thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions if you like
this video you can check out my books
which are linked in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon if you have a math topic or
puzzle suggestion you can email me presh
at mind your decisions calm and you can
also catch me on social media either at
mind your decisions or at presh tell
walker